hey guys welcome back to new hostage
news today we are going to be talking
about all things Captain Marvel we're
also gonna cover star wars episode 9
stuff
iron fist season 2 trough and also
there's a really interesting theory
about spider-man far from home and more
I'm Philip Malina joining me today are
Maude Garrett and Sam basher whoa
if you're wondering where Eric is a
quick Sam where's Eric sick alright but
let's get right into it guys so our top
story is Captain Marvel marvel how
exciting with these pictures basically
you've probably seen it by now
Entertainment Weekly dropped a
first-look spread this week and Eric
actually shot a video going into every
single video or sorry every single photo
in detail because that's our brand and
that's what we do but I thought we could
still talk about what we know about the
story itself so far so first things
first it's set in the 1990s a very newly
hip time again Nine Inch Nails ease you
know that's a reference that most of
their audience won't get Harrison but uh
why why is it said in the 1990s let's go
ahead and throw out some theories Oh
interesting well I mean you want the we
like in the synopsis you saw that you
want a time period where you don't have
any of the other ventures present you
know the D THAAD Captain America Iron
Man's just being a frat boy kind of
being unlikable all around and I don't
know it's it's an interesting kind of
area to play in because we've see a lot
of properties right now they're kind of
dipping their toe in 80s in the soldier
and I think there's a one right so
competing with Wonder Woman and when you
think about it the superhero movies from
the 90's consisted of Schumacher's
Batmen steel so I think they're
redeeming the 90s superheroes the movies
you think like going hey cuz yeah they
were so campy right so it's like it
would be introduced you like let's do it
again hey we've got the time Stern yeah
you know you know what's funny is that
if you go back and re-watch anything
from the 90s superhero stuff you're like
watching like you know last action hero
SRIA Lee can't be stuff mask was amazing
I'm sweaty it also like paints the 90s I
was like the weirdest time we're like
cartoons were a lot
like know why it was just why not yeah
but also like that wasn't life like
everything was like zigzag shaped yes
like world but it wasn't actually but
it's interesting this idea that kind of
magis said of like if it goes back to
the 90s and actually like this what the
90s were actually like like what if it's
all grunge or something yeah or if they
go I mean we're not gonna get this but
imagine if they did go into like the
aesthetic of the non 90s that we always
saw in the movies with the zig zags and
90s which also would be cool cuz I think
that would probably be a reaction to the
fact that the 90s are so hot right now
like I think that they're kind of
honestly just trying to ride that wave
like if you go to Urban Outfitters it's
like oh oh yeah if you go to shop my
what dark just-just-just shop what yeah
but before you start absolutely
thrashing the aesthetic no I think I
mean I I own a number of these things
but it's it's specifically stuff that I
remember like wearing in elementary
school is just as many holes as the
version I'm about to buy for 35 dollars
but I do we think it's that it's that's
that's just said there's not like I like
it has to be the 90s because in the 90s
this amazing Marvel thing happened I
think we've had a lot of the tooth that
early 2000s late 2000s and then 40s I
guess but they've been mapped out enough
so it's like let's see what set the
groundwork for shield that's a good run
a good place a good playground to be in
because shields been around for a while
and while I watch agents of shield
majority of people don't so it's like
they still have an open playground for
what shield was about especially in the
early days because like shields been
around for since the 40s that's where
he's established because of Captain
America shield doesn't actually go into
this period we're talking about it goes
back to the origin of shield and there's
like a few years like May is like you
know they have a little bit of history
but it's like is that 18 months before
the pilot you know but yeah to go back
to straight-up like when Nick Fury got
to eyes and he's like kicking ass and
he's like actually in the field instead
of like just like showing up randomly in
a bar like that's great I have a real
answer now Sam your answer was not real
even though again going back to Jim
Carrey Riddler was amazing but I think
what's happening now is that when the
marble slate pretty much came about it
was in the naughties it was in the early
2000s kind of era ish you know and that
was when iron man was pretty much the
most powerful superhero and it was quite
stagnant and then boom he kind of shows
up I think that in the 90s we are
establishing who Carol Danvers is and
why she is the most powerful entity on
the work in the planet on this
everywhere so when something's gonna
happen here where she disappears right
and then obviously we know from the
cutscene that Nick Fury with one eye has
called upon her so they have this
relationship so I've got to get her back
because you know obviously gone down so
much but I think in this movie we're
gonna understand just how much power she
does actually hold oh absolutely they
were already preparing to where as the
strongest hero I mean we have Thor who
was who's stronger and infinity war than
he's ever been and they're like yeah
she's like more powerful which is
appropriate but I like that idea that
it's just also the logic of like it
needs to be said in the 90s because
otherwise what was she doing when
Ironman was like doing she around so
it's great but also just moving on we're
gonna keep this discussion kind of
moving to different points so if you
have other stuff we want to talk about
what I getting to it for instance we
know that Ben Mendelsohn is gonna be
playing the leader of the scrolls
they're bringing the scrolls to the MTU
which is crazy because it means so many
things are about to get into if you
don't know they're an alien race who are
able to freaking shape-shift it's like
one of the like the few things that was
missing from the MCU Ben Mendelsohn Ben
Mendelsohn is hot dude alias with that
thick Clark Kent No so the scrolls are
also the enemy of the Kree who we
actually did meet and guardians of
galaxy we've also seen a little bit of
them in agents of shield it's really
gross actually in humans yes thanks so
generally those Scrolls are bad guys but
here's what I think is super exciting
about this considering their ability to
shift their shape I don't want to say
shape-shift too many times cuz I'll lose
my tongue do you think that there's
anybody who is already in the MCU who is
currently secretly a freaking scroll the
enemy
I'm trying to think of like a character
who's kind of changed a little bit and
the biggest character that's changed the
most is Thor from like 1:00 and 2:00 to
3:00 that was like a personality
explanation of like they're like no it
wasn't the directors changing it was
he's been a scroll the whole time let's
hear it okay so there's a character that
we've seen at least from Avengers moving
forward who's kind of been a ward or the
second-in-command or a partner to Nick
Fury and I think there's a cool way to
set up their relationship in this movie
because a lot of the times in comics
scrolls show up and they're always bad
guys they're the shapeshifters sometimes
they can even get abilities from like
usually Fantastic Four that's where they
popped up sometimes they've even taken
on other Avengers abilities but there's
also Scrolls that have worked with
people and they've been on our side
what if Maria Hill is secretly been a
scroll this entire time and she's just
chosen like this is what I look guys
it's in front of us it's a classic trope
in every shapeshifter real quick I'm
just gonna respond to that
yes I would absolutely take the form of
Maria hill why not you know yeah big fan
of How I Met Your Mother
yeah it's a sign up said how you're made
I want to look like that
wait go go deep in this she's there a
big fan of her Canadian pop star persona
from that show and then they just took
that on change the hair so it's like now
you can't recognize me at all it's a
short high cut that's what it is but
sorry what's your what's your theory
it's goddamn Hawkeye why do you think
why do you think he left when it went
down because he's a scroll and he goes
captain out of there he got deep we need
all of this girls on where else was he
why was he missing Foreman mod you could
check out our video on where was he
nobody watched I think but here's my
pitch alright it's not the most exciting
one but it's just like one of those ones
right I think it's gonna be someone at
this level Everett Ross oh it's just
that kind of person you've been a thorn
in our side for a lot you were recently
you were there in Civil War but you know
it's like why is he manipulating things
why do making things harder but he's
actually not a real bad guy
why did you keep going back he's been a
scroll the whole time also like it would
just make that character interesting
interesting I mean also if you went with
the comic background of him becoming Red
Hulk could be cool but also there is
something cool that someone
and the government is has been
infiltrated he the mole yeah everyone
high up in the government is either a
scroll or a lizard and then lastly I we
know that this movie has to end with the
scene models referencing from infinity
war Nick Fury probably gives her a
beeper or she gives him one or they in
they exchange I love you one for three
but uh what were what I'm wondering
about is actually where that moment
leaves her like he's if you can give her
a beeper then does that what does that
imply about where she's been this whole
time right if it's like cuz I initially
was thinking like oh she's stuck in the
quantum zone and he's like take this
paper with you so what are what are you
guys his guesses for where she's been
the whole time considering she probably
is gonna have a beeper on her okay so
the synopsis of the movie that came out
was that she has not been on earth when
this movie started she's already with
Star Force not my favorite name but with
the Kree army and she's been doing her
intergalactic due diligence so she comes
back to earth because the scrolls are
invading her responsibilities not here
like she's gonna have relationships
because of the Air Force because of her
family or a number of things but really
deep down I think she's going to return
to the stars and actually be a protector
for the Curia especially we know Ronan's
in this movie in guardians of the galaxy
he's now like a religious zealot he's
kind of gone off the was off the
reservation something like that
and so she's we had a very specific
focus for protecting the Kree Empire and
also I think because Jude Law's
character they're gonna have a very
tight-knit relationship whether it's
romantic or not I kind of hope it's not
but I hope it means something to both of
them I think we're going to possibly
lose him and since he's higher up in his
rank in the Kree military force she
feels duty to have to take his place and
that's where she's been this whole time
and to be clear the Kree like Wars and
stuff are in the grand scheme of the
galaxy and the universe much more
important than day-to-day like earthly
life no yeah I agree
so you're coming you commit to that okay
I'm just gonna throw something out just
because I don't agree with anything you
said Sam nice no I'm kidding it sounds
probably right but here's my beef with
it if the
biggest thing that's ever happened in
the history of the Marvel Universe
happened and they're like how would you
solve it we're gonna spend a year trying
for how are they gonna solve it and
they're like oh she just can't gonna
come back and she's God powered that's
literally deus ex machina right like the
hand of God is gonna come in and like
and it's fixed and I don't like it being
that easy so I want us to have a hurdle
of getting her back and the I like
thinking of like what's the hardest
hurdle
so it's she's been banned from earth for
some reason and she specifically can't
yeah eggs out and she specifically
cannot come back she's not allowed to
come back and they have to find a way to
make it so she can come back otherwise
it's just like Oh 911 page gotta go save
today what if his name was Nick calm
before that happened my immediate
reaction is to go to the courthouse and
change my name
all right so obviously there's so much
more to talk about we're gonna be
talking about Captain Marvel a lot in
the coming weeks but before we move on
to our next topic I've been very cagey
about something that I've been like
owner officers gonna do this new thing
Luke Cage I have not been Luke Agee but
I wish I could be to look cagey all
right and it's time to tell you guys
what that new thing is so I I actually
have been like working a lot on this so
I'm actually like pretty proud of it but
also like yeah Sam's been doing stuff
too it's this new Chrome extension
called scener so if we can pull it up on
screen yeah so scenar
is exactly what I've been waiting for
for the length of time that I've been
working on new rock stars it's a Chrome
extension that lets you give your take
on the shows and movies you love by
actually watching it overlaid on top of
where you're watching it like Netflix or
Hulu but it's perfectly synchronized to
that spot in the movie so the thing when
you watch a breakdown of bars where we
are like painstakingly trying to find
the exact moment in the exact scene that
we're talking about
our editors have to search for it and go
back and forth and pick the wrong one
and we fight with them and then if we
get real sad instead of doing that we
just overlay it directly on top of the
movie and it's on Netflix or Hulu where
you're already watching it
that's what scenar can do you can create
share watch video commentary
synchronized streaming shows movies and
clips from Netflix Hulu and YouTube
actually which is a whole other thing
that we've been playing with and it's
ansmann going back and watching a lot of
his old YouTube content and just
laughing at how dorky he dressed I
let's roll by graphic real quick that
you can own your own commentary know
this or you could also watch the video
where you're a background dancer come
turn that but you could you a commentary
on anything and you guys can do it just
with your webcam on your laptop so
here's you gotta do go to senior comm
slash new rock stars on your computer
and you can just watch the stuff we're
making we already drop something there
we did a Doctor Strange breakdown and
it's again it's just coding you're gonna
go to Netflix you're gonna watch Doctor
Strange and little Erik Bosse and make
hi guys and then he's gonna tell you
these things about Doctor Strange and
like you know the Easter eggs we found
but in the moments where they actually
happened on screen I'm so excited about
this scene er they say it's time to make
a scene you got to see a bunch stuff
from Sam and his friend DJ on their only
stupid answers we're gonna convince mod
to get on there at some point I'm so
excited we're gonna be talking about a
lot we're gonna do it exclusive
breakdowns on there the big announcement
is that like we're putting all this new
content on Netflix essentially the the
movies that you guys have been asking
for we're gonna be doing some of those
things some breakdowns of TV shows you
guys been asking for we're gonna get to
do it on there because honestly it's
also just easier for us than the amount
of editing we normally do super excited
check it out moving on to the trivia
question
okay uh-huh man how does Eric talk so
much sometimes and like my toes got
tired but it is time for this week's
trivia question so let's bring it up
you guys ready immediately broke
everything all right it's pretty it's a
pretty simple question
Oh songs it's not science uh are you
ready you can use it distribute you guys
ready at home - what is Sam are you
ready mmm what is Captain Marvel Carol
Danvers this is middle name all right
and we're back
answers are in here and moving forward
later in the show we'll reveal the
answer to that trivia question the
closest answer is decided by our judges
we're off screen here are gonna do our
sign off goodbyes at the end in any way
they want to but the loser will partake
in that trivia punishment of acting out
something real stupid and you get turned
into the mod Wow I'm very impressed stay
tuned for that later
but moving on actually mod you have some
Star Wars Episode I washed off we've got
new set photos and this is a huge thing
because obviously Star Wars like to make
sure that no one catches glimpses of
anything and they take extreme measures
to hide it all but this is an exterior
set it's kind of like in some sort of
jungle this is episode nine of course so
I kind of want to speculate where we
think that this location is going to be
within the Star Wars universe now people
are speculating that it kind of looks
like there's like some sort of swamp
matter and there's like draping kind of
vines which is a little bit Dagobert
Dagobah they go [ __ ] I think it looks a
little redwood forest II as well right
as where and the moon of Endor was
taking place the forest moon of Endor
really but then the pictures are kind of
forest yes I know and there's a that's
pretty much where the Millennium Falcon
was stationed which again reminds me of
them pulling up to the bunker in episode
308 wait no
technically wait wait a second I
personally think that we're gonna have
another thing happen like what we had
with jakku which is where we saw a lot
of sand and everyone's like oh man we're
back at a 2-week and it's like kidding
it looks exactly like Tatooine but it's
not it's this planet you've never heard
of I think that's my guess too is it's
gonna be just like a brand new planet
because they want to play with the new
in a new sandbox we're like why I like
go to something that's ready been done
when he could have invent literally
anything but this is probably gonna be a
new planet and Sam has a name go
actually I have a pretty good theory and
the names coming hold on okay it's all
right so based on these photos you
looking at you've seen the green room
and it actually looks kind of familiar
and especially the sets they look super
familiar but what's giving away the most
for me are these power machines down
here with a with a god knows hands down
below I'm feeling it could be earth
specifically the United Kingdom that's
the UK location number two so we might
be getting multiple locations on earth
I've never seen the Star Wars franchise
ever seem to dip their toes here I know
it's a galaxy far far away but just how
far are we willing to go to win the war
what's the name of the gods in the Star
Wars universe what did they call earth I
need to pretend yeah Britannia all right
I think that's in some Kingdom I was
thinking of Botanica from glove all
right guys Star Wars Episode nine comes
out December 20th 2019 so if it's
Britannia we owe Sam a big old kiss but
actually Sam has more stuff to talk
about because iron fist season two drop
we assured it it dropped today as we
were recording and actually last night I
tried to watch it but I went to sleep
cuz I'm an old man now but iron for
season two has dropped and allegedly it
is pretty good and then I'm on Episode
one as of recording this at which point
did you go to sleep uh here's the truth
I actually wanted to continue watching
the show after episode one okay and the
best improvement the best praise I can
give it is that the fights actually look
amazing did you say Daredevils peep
all they needed to do they got Creed's
people the guy they did in its and they
actually get ads where he came out and
was like don't worry
the fights actually when it I think the
best way to describe it is that when you
see a punch in the first season it was
kind of like people's hands are moving
around and you're like okay whatever but
in this when a punch lands and you can
see that it's the actor who is doing the
stunts when it lands it's kind of like
everything in the opponent's like body
kind of crumbles and you can see the
environment move with it it's like
you're seeing an actual like visceral
fight happening if there's something
that's staged and I think one of the
best prices also Danny's a thousand
times more likeable and calling Williams
kind of the star of the show but anyways
reviews are agreeing with me that the
show's improved because it focuses less
on Danny and more on the supporting
characters specifically calling wing
this is her show you should give her our
daughters of the Dragon show with her
and misty she's so great yeah and real
quick just on that fighting thing that's
honestly was like my biggest letdown
Rose like you know what story's not
great it's all over the place the acting
is a bit wooden and all over the place
so give me good fighting from an iron
fist show and then it kinda had that
problem that I have with ant-man and the
wasp where it's like oh you guys are so
good at dodging yeah and it's like
dodging is like unfulfilled potential
just builds up and he's like it doesn't
feel like a fight it's like two air
conditioners pointed at each other
you're like I don't I know there's
collisions but I guess what's happening
one of the most iconic moments from
season one I think was Danny going like
this and just missing a punch and it's
like that's what that show was you can
see the hand of the actress but I know
but the reviewers are agreeing with me
and I think it's due to their new
showrunner Raven Metzner who's worked on
Sleepy Hollow falling skies as well and
the Jennifer Gardner Elektra movie they
wrote it
they didn't direct it so that and now
they're sure running this show and I
think it's for the better but are you
guys willing to give it a second chance
so what would you think because it's
like a second great season doesn't
really matter if the first seasons
rubbish does it to be fair
Parks and Rec is a good example of the
little angels a little rough well angels
a bigger deal in season two but also
like just season one of us so it was I
hadn't found it so many shows haven't
found their voice in season one the
office season one is very different
movie after absolutely won money numb
that parts directed the same thing yeah
past there did I with Parks and Rec yeah
so giving it another chance
instant that's an amazing show and I
think the show is worth at least watch
the first episode if you're at all
interested in martial arts I think
that's the best way to say it is like if
you want to see some cool fighting and
some winks and nods to the wider emcee
or just the Marvel Netflix shows go for
it as it is it's tough on you rockstars
that people can do just to get the cheat
sheet survive there maybe it depends on
how much you guys requested is being
totally honest with you guys so this is
what this is a real sad thing about Iron
Fist it killed the momentum of the
Netflix MCU Netflix part of it like
Netflix was shutting down because people
too many people watch Luke Cage season
one right yeah yeah it was insane
everything was blunt Jessica Jones such
a like an obscure character and it
freakin killed and everyone loved it and
people couldn't wait and an iron fist
comes out and legitimately the reason
they say changed all their production
plans after that and honestly you guys
kind of stopped watching our videos
about the Netflix Marvel stuff so it's
hard for us because what takes us so
much time to put in video like a this
would be ten hours of watching something
but you could go to seen her and you
could watch Sam potentially on the new
Iron Fist you also watch Iron Fist
season one on there right DJ and I
rewatched it for you yes and we can do
something like that too so if you guys
request that that's a lot easier for us
to do is to just like overlay it on
through scenery on Netflix but we'll see
if you guys requests are enough let's
move on to another interesting theory
this one is in the part of the MCU we
all really like spider-man far from home
latest buzz is it a prequel specifically
to infinity war so did it not
necessarily a prequel to like when
Spiderman wasn't spider-man
just go drama no specifically does it
come out in a timeline as before
infinity War part 1 so there's some
evidence here before you're like no or
yes whatever so I'm gonna kind of like
share with you guys then on the other
side you can tell me what you guys think
first of all we already know Cobie
Smulders is going to be in it
Sam Jackson with two eyes is gonna be in
it I not true all right I made that up
but Sam Jackson with one eye is gonna be
in it
and then Tom Holland obviously is gonna
be in it so spoiler you know he yeah
there survives infinity war somehow or
it's set before that right so these are
all people that were dusted so either
it's set after infinity war or before
the confusing part about that though is
that this movie comes out on July 5th
2019 infinity War part 2 comes out May
3rd 2019 very close to each other which
means wouldn't we have seen trailers for
spider-man before we've seen infinity
War part 2 how do they make trailers
that aren't gonna spoil who survives
infinity War part 2 unless that those
trailers do not imply survival because
this movie is set before infinity war
another piece of evidence the shots of
Peter Parker on the bus an infinity war
those a lot of people are theorizing
could be him on his way to a far from
home location maybe he is coming to from
the airport maybe he's just had those
experiences maybe he's on his way to the
airport and then instead of going to the
airport the events infinity War part 1
happened and that version is actually my
favorite possible theory because say he
was on his way to the airport and the
instead the event of infinity War part 1
happened what if I what actually is
happening in this moment is infinity War
part 2 happens and we'll find out they
do have to use time travel in order to
fix the events infinity War part 1 and
so if spider-man had been on his way to
the airport instead he got derailed by
infinity War part 1 they go back make
infinity War part 1 never happened and
then BOOM he goes to the airport and
which that's the side sort of scene
which means it would actually be an
alternate timeline story that would be a
glimpse at what the timelines gonna be
back after infinity War part 2 that's my
favourite possibility you guys let me
know what you think and
by the way but what about you - are you
guys convinced that this is a prequel
this has to be because you know he he's
not he's not alive but it's a prequel is
that we know but the technique comes out
after infinity War part 2 so then once
we've finished all the infinity war
action why would we then want to kind of
go back to where it all began so they
would have to be some sort of time trial
travel element to link it all together
otherwise what's the point if it just
resets like a sitcom episode of episode
of friends or everyone's back where they
started yeah or if it is if it takes
place to the events leading up to the
infinity war but it's like again once
all the wars over why would you want to
see what happened before it there has to
be some sort of tying I feel for it to
make sense I think if you did a prequel
you could kind of sidestep all the
trauma that would have to go with dying
and then coming back so I think you it
you'd save a little bit of that but also
in the infinity war because I watched it
like seven times now it came out they're
going to the MoMA they're going to the
Museum of Modern Art is not to have to
derail that totally but they don't
really same with modern airports modern
airports more modern are in London he
just he was like wait wouldn't you just
say you're going to the airport he was
like I'm sorry there was an alien
attacking I didn't really think maybe
that's the alternate timeline version
looks like I'm turning his bus to the
airport instead he's like I've always
wanted to see you London you gotta get
you away from the aliens the plane and
then they take off I mean I think we
solved it yeah but I think you guys are
probably gonna like you know think this
to death a little bit in in at home and
then you can let us know in the comments
hey I have it figured out and then we'll
shout you out if you guys do in a year
and then you get a big smooch - then we
just give those away so easily oh man
alright alright now moving on to a joker
movie casting news yes because this week
we found out that the roles for Robert
De Niro and Mark Marin who have been
confirmed to be in Todd Phillips Joker
movie that's the one with Joaquin
Phoenix he's gonna play a version of the
Joker who's a washed-up comedian
whatever feelings you have on that movie
let's continue
De Niro will be playing a late-night
talk show host which is interesting and
Marc Maron will be playing the show's
producer which
that I would have switched that but
maybe the Joker will be doing you know
an on-set late-night show performance I
don't know what do you guys think
honestly like maybe he goes on in he
bombs on national television right
usually the the television night late
night show and produce a pot is only a
fraction of a movie so I'm trying to
figure out why I would have liked names
this big to only feature in that kind of
thing unless it's like the end goal and
then that super weird like the goal is
like the joke the only way I can be a
stand-up comic is if I get on this show
kind of true for some people but it's
like is that really the goal for the
movie and also by the end of it are you
saying that he turns into the Joker a
comedian think of any comedian you know
but by the end of it he is the worst
serial killer ever written right well I
I so I think he's not gonna by the end
of it be the worst serial killer ever
written right I think that's something
that happens to him right so it's an
origin story so if Cena as an origin
story you want to see this moment where
your main character in this sense it's
gonna be the Joker gets one big
transformation this moment that is like
this huge life-altering moment and if
instead so normally he's that he's in
this version of the story he's a
comedian who's failing a lot right he's
just like not getting last when he when
he goes up at the clubs I that's a very
slow way to show that and in a movie you
don't tend to do it that way you tend to
have a very specific moment in the movie
where everything that was already kind
of goes bad gets a whole nother level of
bad so I think yeah that national TV
version of failing in front of everyone
in the US is huge and then if that's the
moment that starts to form him then yes
I could actually see that the arc of
that movie is going to be about him
getting back the people that turned him
into what he is and then by him
punishing them
that's his turning over into becoming a
murderer or psychopath but not quite yet
like the world's worst murderers
Psychopaths unless you know he kills a
bunch of people with them but you don't
we might I just hope they don't dance
around the like when the last time we've
seen television studios within this
universe I will have the Incredibles to
is when I use like the transmission to
be able to control mind control people
oh thank you yeah thank you Incredibles
too but if that's the Riddler to do that
yeah well it also reminds me of the
Batman with Jack Nicholson where he on a
newscast he he keeps him laughing the
laughing gas stuff whatever he kills
them essentially into that like it could
be any of these things it could be but
you guys let us know in the comments
down below which one you think is the
best or do you think the Robert De Niro
could be secretly Batman yeah also can't
you tell that Robert De Niro is like a
jar something I was like we got to put
you in a superhero something I'm the
Joker whatever actually do listen here
cuz I got a few little bits of news that
we're not gonna cover in depth but it's
definitely worth worth knowing
last week we actually discussed about
the popcorn off Oscar that was gonna
happen in the Oscar ceremony which was
all about the popular movie they've
actually nixed it already that's
happening immediately there was a there
was a board meeting and they were like
we don't have this figured out at least
for next year maybe I think it's dead I
know they said they delayed it but I
think it's dead yeah I figure something
else out
a little bit of news you know Jessie
Graff's she's the American Ninja Warrior
contestant she was dressing up as Wonder
Woman which is actually gonna be working
as a stunt woman on Wonder Woman 1984
and guys I've got a theory
blonde hair cheetah Oh interesting woman
yeah totally and also like she has that
height to that like except you know
Kristen Wiig needs to start lifting it
yesterday I can never get this I think I
even called him my sister to his face
and I was like your sister I'm his
sister from another mister the character
sorry Drac scene goddesses Gary galaxy
wow talk mode I'm like picturing him
beating me up I have to write my will
anyway he say he may not be in Guardians
3 and that his movies on hold
indefinitely he's angry guys he is not
happy with Disney he didn't like the
decisions that were made
yeah now he was throwing his arms around
yeah and also when he was starting to
talk about infinity war he's like it was
a lot of not sure oh it is he's like
trying to get fired kinda right like you
know there's a severance that we don't
know about this Fria Carrie I don't know
yeah I have to find out who knows
alright well thanks for those updates
and now it's time for the new rosters
news lightning right but you guys
tweeted these questions and our social
media person and other picked ones that
we were not allowed to see so we're not
gonna know what to say to this but we're
gonna do actually a couple this time
normally we only do one so we're gonna
go real fast all right you guys ready
I'm gonna fire them in my co-host we're
so ready Maude ready
no are you ready okay okay but I'm first
alright for me from at and long Bunko
fan three what's your favorite horror
film currently it follows but I'm always
loved Halloween the original Halloween
boom on a true scorn if you could
interview anyone living dead or
fictional who would it be Princess Zelda
at hybrid stick once and uh cast
yourself and your co-hosts as Batman
villain ooh
Riddler penguin who do you want to be
poison ivy I've been exercising so you
wouldn't call me penguin anymore but
doesn't matter what at Carla Greed's
what do you think of people comparing
the Wonder Woman and Captain Marvel
movies as a female comic fan by the way
sending some love from house so what do
you think of this comparison between
these I haven't ever been comparing them
I hasn't been in the forefront of my
mind it's just something that I haven't
done at all I've always kept them quite
separate so I mean it's only because
there are only two kind of female driven
movies at the moment right actually
because
there were more than we people wouldn't
compare them so there should be more
true scorn wants me if my gray hat was
an alien controlling my body to gain
intelligence on humanity for an invasion
of Earth or Britannia how long do you
think it would take for your co-hosts to
discover okay wants to know would you
prefer to fight with no weapons or armor
closed arena kill-or-be-killed style one
horse-sized duck or a hundred duck-sized
horses one more time one hundred
duck-sized horses horses don't tear you
apart nails was Thanos a victim of his
own snap I don't think so but I'll snap
that would be if he was no I think
whoever wields a gauntlet can't be hurt
by it unless they want to be ooh like a
masochist mark adds a pata oh jeez a
pata 89 who should lead the MCU past
Avengers for Captain Marvel Black
Panther Doctor Strange the wasp Luke
Cage or etc' man um theoretically it
should be Doctor Strange because he's
got the most ability um but who I want
to lead who are the last ones oh thank
you oh I want I haven't seen Captain
Marvel yet so I don't know she's a
captain doesn't matter I I should know
I'm not convinced yet I'm gonna say wasp
wasp a wasp and Sam finally at dead nab
tricks which superhero costume would you
like to own MCU or DC what do you want
to wear in your little downtime what do
you want to put on you can't say no you
got it yeah this is easy
it's the ant-man costume for the first
movie have you ever seen that baby that
baby is sweet and the mask pops in and
eyes goes boom boom boom boom no bond
and I are bone
in the DC movie guys let's be real it
makes no sense when he put Suns by also
he has to be screwed into that thing
makes no sense real quick Sam has worn a
flash costume he made it himself what a
picture
alright it's time for our 15-second
shout outs each of us is going to get 15
seconds on the clock to shout out plug
or ramble about anything they want Sam
please start oh I want to shout out
crazy rich Asians because I saw it last
night and it's amazing if you want just
a just a it's enchanting I think that's
the word I would have used it's just
delightful it's like because it's not
perfect but also who cares like what do
you what do you do with this movie it's
it's beautiful its romanticized when you
go in there gonna fall in love with all
the characters and the music definitely
needs to be praised and I love that they
fainted I love the way they dive into
the crazy rich part of it because when
you see what people do with money you're
like oh my god I would never think about
doing that yeah reminds me of our
Emperor's New Groove yeah anyway alright
and then I'm reworking as much of the
doctor Doctor Who as possible so I'm
going back through all the seasons so I
want everyone to tweet me your favorite
episodes and who your favorite doctor is
and your favorite companion and your
favorite catch ups and meetups because I
am watching like four episodes a night
Wow where do you start a lot of people
have this question actually really
quickly on board with Doctor Who so I
went the wrong way about it I'm
fascinated with their regeneration so I
will see the passing on a lot of the
time and then I watched a couple of
episodes per season and now I'm like
figuring out which one that I like the
most and I'm watching it all the way
through and I'm team Clara okay so you
made your home bar cool yeah
and then for my 15 seconds out out you
guys heard me talk about it earlier but
I really did actually work a lot with
scenar
to try to make it exactly a tool for new
rockstars basically so if you can please
download that extension and it's scenar
comm slash new rock stars you install it
and then just like play around with it
and you can even record your own stuff
send it to us by the way I would love to
see what you guys do with it but just
straight up like tweet at us at new rock
stars what you want us to see what you
want to
us watch with you we can do breakdowns
on there we can also just chill out on
the couch like we never do anymore
please don't make the cringe we can
watch human centipede time and time
again actually there's good human side
commentary on there check it out senior
Tom / me rock stars
time for our trivia answer with the
punishment of the gif of shame coming
soon shame soon those mistakes but
here's the question just to remind
everyone what is Captain Marvel Carol
Danvers this is middle name Sam thinks
it's Karen Carol Karen Danvers Carol
Karen no it's current Maude thinks it's
Lucy Lucy Danvers Lucy in this guy with
Danvers yeah FEMA writes Carol the rock
Danvers I mean most powerful figure in
the universe no brainer did he not come
out and around the 90s was he WWE didn't
come out of the 90s he's a CGI character
in the mummy and it's great look it up
yes we embody rubber liquid face he's so
good Oh Sam this is why I only throw
cards throwing anything you guys hit
women in the face oh my god the only one
that hasn't harmed a woman on set not a
while we're recording now okay uh and
then the correct answer of course drum
roll where you don't actually hit the
table please and the answer is trick
question she has two middle names Susan
Jane or Carol Susan Jane Danvers Susan
James this is Susan Jane Carol Susan
Jane Danvers I just think I
Oh Susan Jane I just got it Susan Jane
Carol Susan Jane Danvers how many times
can I say Susan Jane can I say
hopefully answering the card in your
face all right judges who was closest
saying Karen Lucy or the rock approached
the judges bench and they might not
allow it I do you want to intervene
Kevin Karen steering's all right that
was my person very generic simple names
and I have it okay Devon says I win
because I have two words and it's two
words who's a loser Karen or Lucy Karen
over here is gonna have to do art all
right wrong answer saying that he's
gonna have to draw a task adjuster from
the gif of shame box and perform that
task repeatedly while the winner me I
get to read the goodbyes and then you
know we chant as the Sam well you can't
tell me I'm the winner but maybe if I
could sound like the rock I would do it
all the time and just make sure to play
with a Sam stupid gift that he's gonna
have to make in a second and send us
your best social media ok Maureen
consistency and more shame shame shame
shame all right guys thank you so much
for watching this week's episode of
officers news right gets to do the this
in my own style so mod you also have to
do the inflatable car wash man babies
but I'm gonna give the goodbyes I thank
you to my two inflatable co-hosts Sam
basher at Sam basher and Maude Garrett
at Maude Garrett and you can follow me
at fimo
no worries Eric Foss will get well soon
I'm sure
his sickness is just in his mind but
comment down below about what you think
is ailing Eric or any of the topics that
we talked about earlier this episode
tweet us at new rock stars topics he
wanted to cover but also tweet us things
he want us to do on scener we're so
excited to play with them hopefully you
guys are too like this video share it
around and you know I should kind of
take my time here I realized because
really have you guys thought about
subscribing to new rock stars
alright you guys what style subscribe do
Rockstar so deep dives you guys love and
we'll see you next week bye bye
talking